Nothing replaces
a human connection.
And nothing is
going to get you
farther along than to be
able to connect with people.
This class is not only going to
be about being a TV journalist,
though we're going
to get into that.
That's not what this is about.
It's about negotiating, public
speaking, body language.
Shoulders back, head
up, eye contact.
I cannot think of any line of
work that you are not going
to benefit by communicating
effectively and authentically.
You can't fake it.
You can't fake the funk, baby.
It's about sharing
with people how they
can be a better communicator.
Tell you a secret.
Listen.
Genuinely take
interest in somebody.
Look somebody in the eye.
When's the last time that
someone has done that?
This is something
my mama used to say.
"Make your mess your message."
Everybody's got something--
cancer, divorce, unemployment,
fill in the blank.
That's not the tragedy.
It's if you don't take
the time to understand,
why was that placed in my path,
what am I supposed to learn?
I remember when I went on
national TV with Diane Sawyer
by my side.
She's holding my
hand and I announce
that I have breast cancer.
When you allow yourself
to be vulnerable,
you're showing a
strength, not a weakness.
And people see that.
And people will
thank you for that.
Yeah, there are times
when I'm still frightened.
But why would you let fear
keep you from your destiny?
You're looking at
that next lofty goal,
and you're like, oh, how
am I going get there?
The secret to getting
ahead is getting started.
So let's get started.
I'm Robin Roberts, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]